pascal durand le secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous alors que la tension est
persistante entre votre formation et
matignon au sujet bien sûr du projet de
nouvel aéroport pour nantes a les
déchirements à l'ump n'arrive pas tout à
fait à masquer ce que d'aucuns
qualifient votre schizophrénie vous
pourrez répondre sur ce point pascal
durand mais d'autres sujets se profile à
l'horizon qui pourrait mettre à rude
épreuve
votre solidarité gouvernementale je
pense à la transition énergétique avec
notamment ce débat sous haute tension
qui s'ouvre jeudi
qu'at-elle prigent de l' agence
france-presse votre partenaire et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat me
rejoindront tour à tour et puis les
téléspectateurs peuvent intervenir comme
chaque semaine par le biais de
l'application tvcheck de notre
partenaire orange alors parce qu'elle
rend vous allez être reçue ce mercredi
par françois hollande qui consultent
tous les chefs de partis dans le cadre
de la commission jospin sur la réforme
de la vie politique est ce que ce sera
une rencontre à soho tension pour vous
donc certainement pas c'est moi j'ai le
plus grand respect pour la personne du
président de la république et pour la
fonction
donc ça ne sera pas sous haute tension
ça sera en revanche le moment et le lieu
d'un échange et d'un débat respectueux
des règles républicaines mais
démocratique je pense qu'au sein de la
majorité il y à là
il y à il ya un certain nombre de points
que nous avons nécessité d'évoquer
ensemble nous a demandé des
clarifications wii ou même simplement du
débat vous savez par exemple sur notre
dame des landes vous vous évoquez
rapidement dans les titres cette
question là sur notre dame des landes ça
fait quelques semaines que j'attire
l'attention et du président de la
république et du premier ministre et
plus largement de leurs services sur la
nécessité d'ouvrir un dialogue et donc
je vais mais je me réjouis après on est
on dira de mots sur les conditions avec
elle cette commission peut fonctionner
mais nous demandions nous la désignation
d'une médiatrice ou d'un médiateur
depuis plusieurs jours donc je me
réjouis de voir qu'un espace de dialogue
va enfin être instaurée dans ce dossier
d'accord un espace de dialogue mais en
fait pour le premier ministre et pour le
parti socialiste
écoutez c'est clair c'était encore se
fera ses dires et pc via retenez l'aller
compris oui la méthode cauet en
politique et pas nécessairement toujours
la solution la plus efficace pour
arriver à une solution partagée et
démocrates la méthode coué la méthode
cauet s'est il suffit pas de dire ça se
fera ça se fera ça se fera pour que ça
se passe il faut que les conditions à la
fois juridiques
j'ai dit à mes conditions
environnementales les conditions
économiques parce que on va on va parler
évidemment des conditions dans
lesquelles cet aéroport éventuellement
se construire et geder soient remplies
pour qu'il se fasse et donc moi je pense
mais je le dis sans aucune arrogance que
ce projet ne se fera pas à cause des
éléments objectifs qui vont être tout
simplement démontrer son il n y en avait
pas obtenu un médiateur vous en appelez
à la l'autorité supérieure du chef de
l'état oui ou oui j'en appelle à
l'autorité supérieure du chef de l'état
mais simplement pour que cette
commission de dialogue puisse vraiment
dialoguer parce qu'un espace de dialogue
il faut que les conditions soient
réunies pour cela je pense et je les dis
ailleurs que le premier ministre n'est
pas dans une situation sur ce dossier de
totale impartialité et je pense qu'il
est temps les éléments
eh bien vous le dites vous même des
plats maintenant depuis si longtemps oui
mais sauf que maintenant il est premier
ministre de la france
il n'est plus le maire de nantes donc il
ya un moment où il faut que la fonction
prime sur sur le passé donc moi je
souhaite que le président de la
république reprennent
j'allais dire l'arbitrage final du
fonctionnement de cette commission de
dialogue
et puis au côté évidemment du
gouvernement il ya trois ministres qui
sont concernés agriculture transports et
écologie je pense qu'on a là des
conditions d'un déjà d'une mise en
cohérence de ces débats vous attendez en
quelque sorte un désaveu du premier
président de la république n'a aucune
chance
non je demande pas du tout ça puisque
vous voyez je suis pas moi du tout dans
le fait de dire la commission dialogue
doit aboutir à quelque chose je dis pour
que cette commission de dialogue
fonctionne il faut une république
impartiale et il faut un dialogue qui
soit serein
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai demandé
mais ça c'est une évidence que le climat
soit apaisée sur place que les forces de
police se retire que toutes les
violences soient arrêtés que le barrage
est un mets évidemment
évidemment que les barbouzes en bonne et
quand même tout le temps aux forces de
l'ordre
pascal durand et jean marc ayrault vous
répond il vous répond notamment dans le
point cette semaine est dit que c'est
impensable que vous écologistes soyez
associés à des anarcho autonome qui font
de la casse à chaque sommet
international sommes pas associés à qui
que ce soit dans ce dossier en dehors
d'un travail conjoint avec les
associations notamment la cipa et les
agriculteurs qui depuis des années mais
avec nous cette lutte je fasse je
rappelle que françois bayrou jean-louis
borloo chantal jouanno jean luc
mélenchon et
et bien d'autres responsables politiques
viennent de faire valoir leur désaccord
sur ce projet je pense que le dossier
notre dame des landes mérite beaucoup
mieux que de rentrer dans la caricature
des positions des uns et des autres nous
premier ministre dénonce nuit des
caricatures et les chiffres de mode
qu'ils ne tombent pas la mairie qui
entoure ce projet qui rappelle-t-il a
été acceptée par les trois quarts des
agriculteurs concernés sur la zone
d'écouté y est soutenu par des élus
écoutent ne gauche à droite pas les
centristes vous l'avez rappelé deux mois
mais pas simplement mais au delà c'est
sait pas que c'est pas la question la
question que nous avons c'est que nous
avons un projet qui en l'état partait
sur le transfert d'un aéroport de nantes
atlantique qui existe qui n'est
absolument pas saturés qui est pas
aujourd'hui mais à perdre ibama d'accord
mais enfin pour le moment il ne l'est
pas et le nombre de vols de rotations
aériennes est le même en 2012 que ce
qu'il était en 2000 donc déjà toutes les
projections qui ont été faites au départ
sont fondées interroger les nantais qui
sont les premiers rounds à un pire les
gens sont bien sûr on a même visité le
maire avec le maire de la commune qui
est à côté sur laquelle se situe
l'aéroport a fait la visite avait cloué
à rappeler à quel point elle tient à ce
que cet aéroport reste dans cette
commune ne serait-ce qu eu égard aux
emplois qu'ils y sont donc donc ne là
non plus une caricature ou pas
simplement ce que je rappelle c'est que
cet aéroport nantes atlantique existe
que le nouvel aéroport aurait vocation à
détruire près de 2000 hectares et avec
l'âge et le gran turismo yad'autres avec
tous les anciens ministres l'aéroport
s'il existait donc il est pas enclaver
puisqu'il est encore plus d'un million
de passagers qui peuvent le prendre
donc on est très très loin d'être
enclavées par ailleurs il ya 560
millions à investir
moi j'aimerais et j'aimerais qu'on
arbitre le fait de savoir si ses 560
millions il serait pas plus utile par
exemple en développant une nouvelle
ligne tgv est une nouvelle gare tgv à me
permettre d'aller plus rapidement de
montory wah wah cet argent voilà qui ne
manque pas d'arguments être son côté où
on écoute le vol il dit notamment que
tous les anciens ministres des
transports de droite de gauche on avait
il énumère tous nos listes
minutes c'est très bien mais c'est mais
c'est aimer écouter il a le droit
c'est dommage qu'il n'en appelle pas
peut-être aux anciens ministres
agriculture qui aurait peut-être pas la
même position je vois que y compris au
sein de la fnsea
ça bouge la confédération paysanne est
depuis toujours opposée à ce projet on a
une priorité moi je voudrais terminer là
dessus parce que c'est quand même très
très important vous disiez tout à
l'heure la schizophrénie ou tout ça ce
sont des mots moi je pense que les seuls
vous êtes dans le gouvernement et qu'on
le protège je comprends parce que je ne
suis pas contre le premier ministre je
vais me l'ont fait ou la wii le moi
j'étais une opposition forte j'entends
les laissez moi juste aller au bout
j'étais à la conférence environnementale
j ai entendu le discours du président de
la république puis le lendemain le
discours du premier ministre
je les ai bien entendu j'ai entendu ce
qu'ils nous disaient et ce qu'ils nous
disaient c'était cela c'était un il faut
et c'est une priorité absolue
mais c'est les gaz les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre oui mais donc pas
nouvel aéroport
il nous disait il faut préserver les
terres agricoles c'est absolument majeur
dans les années qui vient est la
troisième chose écoutez c'est toujours
facile ça moi ce que je sais c'est que
les agriculteurs je les ai vus j'ai vu
300 tracteurs sur le site donc 300
tracteurs ça fait quand même pas mal
d'agriculteurs donc cela je les ai
vendus sur ce site
il a dit il faut préserver la
biodiversité voilà donc j'adore je dis
que nous faisons en sorte que le premier
ministre et le président de la
république respectent leurs engagements
a envoyé je suis dans cette majorité
veut freiner non couverte par le
gouvernement est de construire un projet
clé du défendue par le premier ministre
quand même avec avec les regrets quand
même du ministre de vos amis pascal
canfin de ne pas être allé manifester
avec vous notre week-end à nantes
franchement là on est plus dans la
schizophrénie l'équilibriste on est dans
la haute voltige au repas des liquides
mais non parce qu'il dit très bien il
dit très bien qu'il est ministre
maintenant donc il a sa fonction
ministre mais il revenir la peine mais
parce que c'est un c'est encore une fois
cet aéroport sa touche aux fondamentaux
ce projet d'aéroport sa touche aux
fondamentaux de l'écologie pascal canfin
est un écologiste à partir du moment où
les socialistes nous ont demandé de
rentrer avec le gouvernement ce que nous
avons fait c'est un moment pour aussi
prendre en compte ce que les justices
port d'akaba mais dites-moi donc
comprenez rien
enfin il est cohérent c'est comme ça
tout chaud voilà la grande question
c'est absolument j'ai des aéroports vous
nous dites c'est ce que pense également
le premier ministre il a dit dans paris
match l'autre jour on amasse laisser
imposer un projet de société qu'on ne
veut pas et puis il dit à nouveau la
même chose dans dans le point cette
semaine en disant c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on veut nous imposer la
décroissance non mais c est ce que est
ce que c'est sérieux alors qu'il ya un
aéroport qui à 20 km de là et qui a
encore un million de passagers en
possibilités de croissance
nous lui demandons d'être dans la raison
c'est à dire que cet aéroport sur nantes
atlantique n'est pas saturé il y a la
possibilité d'y développer encore des
emplois et à corps et donc non sommes
pas du tout dans ad le poursuivant c'est
pas un bras de fer va certains débats
nous souhaitons un dialogue est la
preuve d une commission de dialogue qui
se met en place
quand on parle de musique on n'a pas
encore parlé à mme duflot mais on
enlèvera sans doute avec arnaud
montebourg vous n'avez traité récemment
de dinosaures de la politique
oui parce qu'il est pro nucléaire parce
qu'il éprouve au gaz de schiste
j'imagine qu'est ce que vous pensez de
sa charge récentes contre mittal alors
est ce que ce sont des profonds seront
approuvés ou les jugez-vous à
l'emporte-pièce north face et ni l'un ni
l'autre jeu j'essaye de dire qu'en
politique les phrases j'allais dire
arrogante quasiment des postures ne sont
pas à la hauteur des enjeux qui se
posent à la france sur florange c'est
quelque chose d'effectivement très grave
il ne suffit pas de dire mittal doit
quitter la france ce sont des milliers
d'employés hind ahmas il n'a pas investi
en france que sur le site de florange où
le savez très bien
et donc on ne peut pas du jour au
lendemain à 6057 enfants exactement donc
ça n'est pas mes l'emploi ça n'est pas
raisonnable de donner à la vindicte
populaire une personne comme ça et de
dire il faut qu'elle quitte la france
comment j'ai encore ce genre de
comportement je n'en ai pas l on
connaissait le ministre
quand j'ai dit que je regrettais ça je
l'avais déjà dit à l'époque contre
peugeot je pense que ça n'est pas la
personne d'un actionnaire ce sont des
choix industriels et j'aimerais que le
ministre du redressement productif pose
les questions des choix industriels et
quant à florange je partage en revanche
sa volonté de faire en sorte que les
pouvoirs publics interviennent mais je
souhaite qu'il le fasse dans une
cohérence c'est à dire quels projets on
peut porter moi j'ai vu par exemple
obama le président obama aux états unis
nationalisé de fait general motors
quand general motors était en crise et
maintenant general motors est reparti
absolument sinon il faut faire attention
à voir la raison n'est pas raison la
sidérurgie c2c pour pas très bien de
quel projet maintenant je sais qu'on
aura toujours besoin d'acier en france
et donc il faut pas être là non plus
dans la caricature et de dire il faut
fermer etc
non alors il faut se donner des projets
industriels il ya des syndicats aussi il
faut parler avec eux allez on va voir
avec katell présent l'agencé france
presse qui va nous rejoindre
comment vous entendez faire bouger les
lignes sur d'autres dossiers le dossier
énergétique et bien sûr au premier plan
avec le débat qui arrive jeudi et qui se
met en place avec peine on voit ça tout
de suite avec faustine saint geniès une
conférence déjà reporté une liste des
intervenants plusieurs fois modifié et
des ong qui claque la porte
c'est dans ce climat tendu que s'ouvre
jeudi le débat national sur la
transition énergétique
parmi les erreurs reproché au
gouvernement le choix des membres de son
comité de pilotage
plusieurs sont de fervents défenseurs de
l'atome comme anne lauvergeon ex-patron
du groupe areva
greenpeace et les amis de la terre
décident de boycotter le débat un échec
pour chantal jouanno
porte drapeau du grenelle de
l'environnement en 2007
pour nous le fait que greenpeace ne soit
pas autour de la table
ça c'est un échec parce qu' il fallait
absolument que tous les acteurs qui
étaient là en 2007 soit là en 2012 il
faut s'inscrire dans la continuité
objectif de la conférence évaluer les
besoins en énergie du pays dans les
années à venir et les satisfaire avec le
moins de nucléaire et des énergies
fossiles mais surtout mettre en musique
les promesses de françois hollande
développer les énergies renouvelables à
améliorer l'isolation thermique des
logements fermer fessenheim et surtout
réduire la part du nucléaire
la production électrique de 75 à 50% en
des mesures qui ont un coût pour la
seule électricité
il faudrait investir 380 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2030 selon l'union
française de l'électricité pas plus de
précisions pour le moment sur le contenu
de la conférence
malgré les objectifs louables ce débat
sur la transition énergétique fait
grincer des dents au sein même de la
majorité
chez les écologistes tant que le
gouvernement vient maintiendra ses
positions sur le nucléaire sur les gaz
de schiste et sur notre dame des landes
je vois pas très bien comment nous
pourrions participer à une un débat sur
la transition énergétique qui n'auraient
qui serait un titre vide de sens
l'ailer s'engage dans un numéro
d'équilibriste auquel ils nous ont
désormais habitué depuis qu'ils sont de
gouvernement beaucoup question je
rejoins vos questions à notre invité
on vient de mon temps donc in peace les
amis de la terre qui refuse de
participer au débat
ça commence déjà mal non c'est un
mauvais début oui ça c'est clair moi
j'ai regretté évidemment que et
greenpeace et les amis de la terre ne
participe à ce débat ça fait des années
que les écologistes souhaitent qu'un
débat enfin en france aient lieu sur
l'énergie qu'on puisse un peu tout
mettre à plat bien sûr que greenpeace et
les amis de la terre ont toute leur
place maintenant moi je suis très
respectueux de l'indépendance des ong et
des associations à partir du moment où
il considère que les conditions ne sont
pas réunies
je respecte leur choix à titre personnel
encore une fois je le regrette
vous considérez qu'il conditions sont
réunies non nous on a fait valoir par
exemple sur la sur la manière dont le
comité de pilotage était mise en oeuvre
nous avons fait valoir un certain nombre
d'observations elles ont d'ailleurs pour
une part était retenu maintenant ce que
j'attends c'est que ce débat on nous
donne les éléments concret de la manière
dont il va se dérouler je moi je ne peux
pas et je n'ai je n'ai jamais
était partisan de la chaise vide vous en
souvenez au moment du grenelle
nous on avait soutenu le processus du
grenelle contre d'ailleurs la vie à
l'époque de noël mamère qui est
d'ailleurs dans une certaine cohérence
par rapport à ce qu'il disait déjà en
nous nous ne considérons pas que eu
égard aux urgences et on va en parler
tout à l'heure climatiques
environnementales il ya deux ans qui
vient de commencer
donc on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
rester à côté et ne pas participer à ce
débat et faire entendre la voix des
écologistes donc nous y serons et nous
porterons ce que nous croyons être bon
pour l'avenir énergétique de la france
un défi bateau a dit que quand le
premier ministre l'avait proposé de
prendre la tête de ce débat l'avez
entendu le générique de mission
impossible
est-ce que vous n'entendiez aussi cette
petite musique vous avez certainement
pas moi je ne fais pas de la politique
pour me mettre dans des situations
d'échec
je pense encore une fois que nous avons
des enjeux majeurs la france en 2025 en
elle se prépare maintenant lorsque la
france a fait le choix du tout nucléaire
à l'époque deux du gouvernement pompidou
puis lorsqu'il était président de la
république
ils ont su investir et ils ont su voir
une vision à 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans donc
maintenant
cette vision est derrière nous il faut
qu'on regarde quelle france on veut
avoir le président de la république a
fixé lui-même la feuille de route c'est
pour ça que moi je ne suis pas inquiet
sur la nécessité du débat il a lui même
dit il faut que nous réduisions il sait
qu'on n'était pas d'accord sur le
principe mais c'est les compromis mois
les écologistes sont minoritaires dans
cette majorité donc nous acceptons des
compromis le président de la république
a dit en 2025 nous voulons réduire la
part du nucléaire est passé de 75 à 50%
très bien nous nous disons sur cette
feuille de route là que nous avons
accepté comment on développe quel type
d'énergie nous développons de manière à
ce qu en 2025 nous ayons compenser pour
une part la baisse de la production
nucléaire et d'autre part que nous ayons
économusée vous êtes en série était à
dire aux français qu'ils reçoivent leur
facture d'électricité tous les mois et
qu'il va falloir payer plus cher le kilo
watt pour financer les énergies
renouvelables si vous êtes prêt l'a dit
tenir devant la caméra ce discours de
vérité eh ben c'est pas un discours de
vérité parce que l'encours de vérité
qu'on devrait le retenir c'est que quoi
qu'il arrive
quelle que soit la nature de la
production énergétique que nous aurons
leurs factures vont augmenter ça c'est
la vérité
et ça c'est le discours que tout le
monde devrait tout de même en gestion
qui seraient imputables à l'homme après
renouvellement c'est pas tout à fait
juste parce que les spécialistes disent
et donc c'est pour ça que le débat doit
avoir lieu que si l'on prenait
l'hypothèse du nucléaire et du
développement du nucléaire comme
quasiment tous les réacteurs arrivent à
terme
ainsi rené une période d'une dizaine
d'années on va être au bout des
réacteurs qui était prévu au départ pour
28 38 40
il y avait à voir tellement
d'investissement à faire que le prix de
l'électricité nucléaire
même en prenant la réalité du vrai prix
c'est-à-dire en mettant le prix du
démantèlement de la gestion des déchets
et les assurances qui ne sont pour le
moment pas pris plus la recherche donc
si on prenait ce prix là nous aurions
une énergie nucléaire qui est aussi cher
que de l'énergie renouvelable se croyait
ses promesses de baisse sachant que pour
l'instant vous l'avez obtenu messieurs
la fermeture de fessenheim et ce
programme et moi je le fais je suis
désolé je suis désolé de le dire je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure comme je ne fais
pas le pari de l'échec comme je ne crois
pas que lorsqu'on commence un débat il
va échouer je ne fais pas de procès
d'intention à partir du moment où nos
partenaires le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
pris un engagement devant les françaises
et les français
je n'imagine pas je ne l'imaginent pas
donc c'est même pas une hypothèse que je
traite qu on a on ne respecte pas cet
engagement
donc nous nous avons une feuille de
route je répète cette feuille de route
c'est la baisse à l'horizon 2000 je
rappelle que nora correct le parti
socialisme ne pas embêter tout le monde
avec ça il y avait également la
fermeture de 24 réacteurs
donc a donc tout ça on va là on va en
rediscuter on va le mettre mais nous
c'est ce qui m'intéresse moi vraiment
c'est c'est que on se donne les moyens
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure la france de
2030 on la prépare pas en 2029
je sais qu'en allemagne le renouvelable
c'est 300 milles l'emploi je veux bien
après qu'on discute de tout sur les
conditions dans lequel nous développons
cette industrie comment on fait mais ce
que je sais c'est que les métiers et
l'avenir l'emploi d'avenir puisque le
président de la république est très
attaché aux emplois d'avenir
il est sur le renouvelable et
certainement pas sur le développement de
la filière nucléaire il n'y a qu'à voir
à quel point le p r à flamanville je
parle même pas en finlande est
encalminée coûte une fortune dépasse
d'année en année son prix d'origine mais
on est déjà plus de 6 milliards fin
quand quand j'entends dire quand j'ai
entendu imaginé avec 6 milliards ce
qu'on aurait pu développer au titre de
la recherche et d'une nouvelle industrie
sur le sur les énergies renouvelables
les investissements que l'on pourrait
faire et les emplois que nous pourrions
créer avec 6 milliards pour le moment où
les gâches totalement donc c'est ça moi
qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas de pot
limit et lui de dire nous allons au
procès d'intention mais vous avez quand
même déjà été échaudé avec la conférence
environnementale cécile duflot avait sa
petite larme à l'oeil à la sortie et au
final maintenant vous trouvez que ça va
pas assez vite notamment sur la
fiscalité que vous êtes déçu avec notre
dame des landes
les raisons vous pourriez même être un
peu méfiants alors j'ai dit ce matin je
suis pas méfiant j'ai conscience que
nous ne sommes pas dans une situation
dans un rapport de force qui nous est
très favorable moi j'ai pas oublier non
plus dans quelle condition nous avons
terminé la campagne présidentielle et la
campagne des législatives ne vit pas
dans un monde en dehors du monde réel
je sais très bien que que au sein de la
majorité y compris au sein du parti
socialiste certains ont tendance à
considérer que les écologistes ne sont
pas nécessairement dans une situation
électorale qui leur permet de extra
j'entends ça donc je sais qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à convaincre et qu'on
arrive à convaincre avec des arguments
de fond et pas simplement dans les
postures politiques ou les rapports de
force me répéter depuis le début de
cette émission que vous n'aimez pas les
chèques vous n'envisagez pas mais
françois hollande il ya quelques
semaines dans marianne dans une
interview accordée à marianne avait dit
que le départ des écologistes du
gouvernement était possible vous allez
lui poser la question ce mercredi c'est
logique parce que nous puissions vous le
voyez mais j'aimais moi je ne me pose
absolument pas la question d'une
participation lui dis que je lisible
mais il a raison comme dans tout couple
ou comme dans toute relation
il ya toujours une possibilité de se
séparer il a dit ils ont la possibilité
de partir s'ils veulent me l'arrivée pas
les résultats je suis écouté moi je fais
pas de l'exégèse je pense que le prêt
d'abord je ne dis je ne sais pas comment
il a dit puisque c'est une intense et l
intérieur la presse écrite mais il dit
une évidence il dit s'ils veulent partir
et les malheurs mais il a raison de ne
pas le dire moi je mets moi je dis
autrement donc entendez moi je dis mais
il n'avons absolument pas l'intention de
partir nous sommes nous dans une
majorité pour faire bouger les lignes on
va attendre quoi d'être majoritaire pour
les dents les yannick jadot eurodéputé
vert qui dit allez on se donne jusqu'au
printemps est là on voir un bilan mais
ciani c'est ce que dit yannick c'est
exactement la même chose que ce que dit
notre conseil fédéral c'est à dire le
conseil politique et il a raison de dire
ça il doit y avoir à un moment où la
présence des écologistes dans une
majorité doit se concrétiser en acte
c'est à dire que nous devons aussi pas
simplement avoir deux ministres qui font
d'ailleurs du bon boulot et qui est
salué par tout le monde mais nous devons
aussi avoir des résultats
c'est un père meilleur c'est pas que ça
tarde il faut le temps moi je sais qu'un
temps de transition mais non mais
laissez nous le temps le débat
énergétique laisser le temps au débat
énergétique de se passer et accepter
qu'on accepte de tirer les bilans qu'une
fois que ce débat énergétique sera fait
il y à une grande loi sur la transition
énergétique qui doit sortir à l'issue de
ce débat et bien attendons de voir cette
loi et sur la base de cette loi et
yannick a raison les écologistes
pourront se poser la question de savoir
s'ils vont eu des avancées ou si au
contraire rien ne s'est passé
idem pour la fiscalité le premier
ministre m'avait promis
il m'avait dit on peut rien faire sur
2013 c'est trop court je l'entends je le
je partage ce sentiment je regrette
qu'on n'ait rien fait sur les niches
fiscales ça on aurait pu le faire dès le
départ il ya 22 milliards mais là on n'y
croit pas on est en train de regarder de
très près les contreparties qui seront
exigées aux entreprises qui vont
bénéficier du crédit d'impôt 1 1
milliard c'est une très bonne nouvelle
le plus on regarde les contreparties et
xavier exigent non c'est mais c'est pas
des termes d'exigences nous avons il y a
nécessiter encore une fois à préserver
l'emploi dans ce pays est une nécessité
mettre des des conditions
environnementales pour préparer
l'industrie et les emplois de demain
c'est également une condition ça n'est
pas une exigence dans toutes les régions
les aides publiques sont conditionnés
dans tous les pays du monde on
conditionne les aides
donc c'est très bien qu'on le fasse
scène il faut pas le voir encore une
fois comme une marque d'exigence mais
comme un besoin de la société et une
gestion s'appelle autre question qui qui
a un petit peu fâché entre le
gouvernement et moi c'est le cas c'est
le gaz de ces gaz de schiste on va y
revenir et là pour le coup c'est aussi
de l'énergie
on dit aux français qu'on a peut-être un
tas d'or sous nos pieds mais qui doit se
serrer la ceinture et qu'on n'ira pas
chercher cette adore ça c'est pareil
c'est d'abord le tas d'or on sait
absolument pas ce qu'il ya donc qu'on
arrête avec là aussi la désinformation
je me souviens à l'époque fait en tout
cas je les lui quelle époque où le gaz
de lacq avait été découvert ça y est
c'est fini la france allait avoir fond
son indépendance énergétique pour la fin
des temps le bilan des camps de mise en
plus tard il y en avait presque plus il
a fallu lancer le nucléaire en
catastrophe et après avec des
investissements considérables
moi ce que je voudrais vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous imposer la question
de la schizophrénie de la avérée des
écologistes moi je voudrais qu'on fait
en cohérence
comment mais expliquez moi comment on
peut tenir les objectifs de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
que le président de la république et
l'union européenne se sont engagés à
faire et où français alors plutôt que
d'importer du pétrole on peut utiliser
celui qu'on a stoppé à aimer non mais
moi je vais vous donner de noms mais
sauf qu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
d'argent c'est quand même pas vous je
vais l'expliquer on nous explique on est
dans un budget contraint donc sur quoi
on met l'argent est ce qu'on le met sur
les économies d'énergie est-ce qu'on
investit sur par exemple l'isolation des
bâtiments vous me disiez tout à l'heure
est ce que je suis prêt à faire en sorte
que les gens payent plus cher leurs
factures non moi je suis prêt à faire en
sorte en mettant l'argent qu'il faut là
où il fort à faire en sorte qu'ils
payent moins de dépenses énergétiques
parce que le prix de l'énergie va monter
s'ils en consomment moins naturellement
de fait ils vont moins dépenser
donc voilà les priorités le
le gaz de schiste c'est l'alcoolique qui
est dans son addiction et qu'il veut
toujours aller chercher le dernier vers
l'est est ce qu'on va sortir de
l'addiction aux énergies fossiles pour
aller vers un autre modèle de société
est annexée où il ouvrait la porte aux
recherches je recherche
au départ c'était non vous étiez très
content c'est exemple il est égoïste et
je sors quand même qu'à chaque fois que
vous avez une prochaine vous n'est parce
que je derrière le chef de l'état a
changé d'habits
c'est là où c'est là notre valeur
ajoutée dans ce gouvernement c'est
d'essayer de faire prendre conscience
que l'avenir l'avenir de l'énergie ne se
situe pas dans la recherche à des fins
illégales et je leur laisse quand même
les chercheurs travaillaient regarder
travailler même obscurantisme
non je ne suis pas obscurantistes mais
j'aimerais que l'énergie des chercheurs
elle soit mise non pas aller je ne vais
pas interdire quoi que ce soit je n'ai
pas qualité pour allah quant à certains
parfois pas chez moi alors j'en
trouverai jamais là-dessus en revanche
j'aimerais que les chercheurs comme en
allemagne où ils sont en train de
travailler sur l'hydrogène de manière
très avancés ils ont beaucoup beaucoup
d' avance par rapport à la france sur
ces recherches là j'aimerais qu'on ne se
trompe pas d'objectif de recherche je
rappelle que 80 pour cent
quatre-vingt-cinq même des brevets sur
les nouvelles technologies sont déposées
aux etats-unis et pas en france
donc voilà il faut aller c'est dur peut
être aujourd'hui plus que jamais le
discours écologiste un pascal durand
parce qu'avec le chômage qui progresse
tenue en et les chiffres du mois
d'octobre plus 45 milles 3 million cent
mille chômeurs c'est difficile à la
balance des aviations c'est très
difficile d'économie un justement
et puis la préservation de
l'environnement et on est d'accord mais
qu'elle est une économie aux relances
moi je répète
est ce que vous pensez ou pas qu'on
pourra se dispenser dans les années qui
viennent par exemple pour l'industrie
automobile de ne pas prendre en compte
les nouvelles modalités de transport
dans les années 2020 2030 2040 ccsa que
nous sommes en train de dire nous
voulons résoudre le chômage nous voulons
aider nous l'avons dit sur la formation
automobile difficile de dire aux gens
que l'on est en train de le dire à paris
par exemple votre voiture de 17 ans on
n'en veut je ne le dis pas moins bien
que les jeunes eux
dis pas parce que justement il faut
savoir distinguer je pense que une
voiture neuve
par exemple avec un très très gros
moteurs qui consomment 20 litres au cent
est beaucoup plus néfastes pour
l'environnement que une 4l ou une dose
de exactement donc chez moi je me dis je
dis en revanche je suis même un appareil
jeudi que cette cette déclaration la
mérite débat et que et que
personnellement si on me parle des
vieilles voitures parlons du diesel
parce qu'effectivement les voitures
diesel sans filtre les voitures avec
filtre c'est déjà un débat mais les
voitures sans filtre à diesel yama de
débat ce sont des milliers de morts en
france qui sont liées aux
microparticules donc nous avons la
nécessité d'agir là dessus donc ça c'est
bon pour tout le monde pour la santé et
pour l'industrie automobile qui se
reconvertira merci qu'apple perrine
tarneaud arrive mais on va d'abord
tenter avant de poursuivre avec elle
dans un instant pascal durand d'en
savoir plus sur vous grâce à l' enquête
menée par marie brémaud mais comment
pascal durand at il atterri à la tête
d'europe écologie les verts
la question est légitime quand on écoute
ses compagnons de galère
moi ça me fait très drôle de le voir là
parce que au début en 2007 ils disaient
ouais faut pas aller voir cécile duflot
faut pas les voir vincent placé c'est
des apparatchiks c'est un appareil
j'ai horreur des appareils et lui se
retrouve à la tête de l'appareil parce
que finalement c'est quand même un
appareil aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui
est méfiant interrogatif vis-à-vis du
pouvoir et vis-à-vis de ce que ça peut
transformer en lui une méfiance laissé
sans doute en héritage par des parents
résistants communistes mais l'homme à 51
aurait-il changé en prenant la tête d'un
parti désormais au gouvernement
la dérive de lego qui va souvent de pair
avec les sphères du pouvoir ne lui ai
pas encore monté à la tête
avocat de formation il défend avant tout
une cause et la joue collectif
il a l'intelligence ne pas chercher à se
mettre en concurrence sur un champ
purement médiatique c'est pas son boulot
son boulot c'est la cohésion du
mouvement s'est passé du temps sur le
terrain faire en sorte aussi de cadre et
d'expression politique officielle du
mouvement
garde de bonnes relations avec quasiment
tout le monde ce qui n'est pas chose
aisée homme de consensus pascal durand
et c'est ainsi qu'il s'est retrouvé seul
en lice pour le poste de secrétaire
national
mais attention au revers de la médaille
une indécision chronique gênant quand on
est censé incarner le leadership c'est
peut-être la plus grosse faiblesse c'est
souvent est systématiquement de vouloir
plaire à tout le monde donc ça peut être
en nombre
handicap pour faire les choix mais
attention l'ancien directeur de campagne
de nicolas hulot est un homme convaincu
ses colères au sein du parti sont
légendaires c'est pas facile de le
côtoyer au quotidien parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est fonceur et qu'elle
quelques fois brutale ou qui s'emporte
mais après tout c'est ça aussi les
qualités de ses défauts ses adversaires
mais ses amis aussi sont prévenus
méfiez-vous de l'eau qui dort voilà pour
connaître une de vos colères il ne reste
un quart d'heure des missions africaines
comme ça vous voilà en tout cas
apparatchiks parmi les apparatchiks vous
qui vouliez à tout prix éviter d'être un
as passé sont les paradoxes de la vie et
les surprises qu'elle vous réserve
quand j'ai commencé avec nicolas hulot
puis dany cohn-bendit laventure d'europe
écologie je m'attendais pas
effectivement à m'asseoir en jour dans
le fauteuil de secrétaire national de
d'un mouvement politique voilà c'était
pas c'était pas c'était pas un choix ce
n'est pas une ambition mais qu'est ce
que ça va frapper alors dans la vie
en tant que comme ça arriver en presque
deux ans à la tête d'europe écologie les
verts voient pas deux ans exactement
parce qu'on a on a démarré au moment du
pacte écologique avec avec nicolas
c'était en 2006 donc bon mais lexie grey
qu'europe écologie on l'a créée en 2008
j'ai eu la chance mais peut-être par
justement par envie par nrj de
construire europe écologie j'ai été le
directeur de campagne aux européennes
samsam a permis évidemment une entrée
j'allais dire par la grande porte parce
que ces élections européennes on les a
réussis nous ont portés et quand il a
fallu fusionner europe écologie avec les
verts est basse et naturellement je me
suis retrouvé en deuxième position
derrière cécile duflot et le hasard de
la vie politique face et 10 très
rapidement dans le sujet moi j'ai les
parents qui se sont engagés donc dans la
vie donc chez moi j'ai toujours eu un
grand respect pour la politique mais un
grand respect pour les vies des
politiques et pour les gens qui peut
être je déteste le cynisme en politique
je déteste des postures politiciennes et
c'est pour ça que j'avais très peur des
appareils que j'ai toujours très peur
des appareils ont tenté de vous prémunir
alors en d'abord en étant collectif ça a
été dit c'est pour moi le là la solution
la première des solutions voyez je le
disais tout à l'heure pour le débat pour
l'énergie etc
moi je crois à l'intelligence collective
l'avocat que que je suis je suis encore
il sait que c'est dans la contradiction
c'est dans le débat qu'on arrive à
construire oui après quelque chose quand
la tête d'un parti faut aussi savoir
prendre des décisions et projets je
crois que je les fais je crois quand il
a fallu prendre position sur le tsg je
les fais je crois que c'est notre dame
des landes
je les fais également très clairement
j'ai attendu avec tous les écologistes
plus facile sur le traité peut-être non
jeu c'était peut-être singulier mais je
me suis à ce moment là vous avez
interrogé andré gattolin andré à ce
moment là étaient sur une position qui
n'était pas la mienne je me suis à ce
moment là séparés entre guillemets de la
position que daniel cohn bendit portée
mais non mais
débat mais est-ce qu'on démocratie on
peut admettre que le monde est pas blanc
du noir
est-ce qu'on peut admettre qu'on est
prêts européens fédéralistes comme moi
et qu'en même temps on considère que le
dscg n'est pas nécessairement une grande
avancée pour l'europe à laquelle je
crois
est ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
sortir sur l'énergie est ce qu'on peut
sortir des clichés en disant oui il ya
que le nucléaire c'est le nucléaire qui
est l'avenir de la france où c'est le
gaz de schiste ou est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on peut aussi aller vers
d'autres pistes faire autre chose j'ai
vraiment du mal à convaincre et pré
cause de vous notre faim mais et c'est
je les dis j'ai remis en cause
enfin moi personnellement peut-être mais
j'ai également remis en cause la manière
dont les écologistes se sont exprimés je
l' ai dit à maintes reprises et je ne
m'en cache pas je considère que nous
avons souvent été beaucoup trop arrogant
est passé dans le dialogue
donc si on me reproche finalement d'être
un homme de consensus et le dialogue
j'accepte cette critique et quelque part
je la revendique je pense qu'en ce
moment on a besoin de recréer du lien et
de la solidarité
et pas nécessairement du conflit et je
sais que la politique à tort le cou
filles adorent les rapports de force
et bah tant pis ce sera un mauvais
politique on va y venir dans quelques
années de rapports de force en en dehors
des verts évidemment je vous laisse
deviner pour revenir sur le reportage
qu'on vient nous voir le sénateur vert
ronan dantec dit finalement le boulot de
pascal durand c'est de garder la maison
la maison des verts ça peut être c'était
de reprendre la formule de léon blum
si si
je dois avoir un héritage je veux bien
après tout prendre celui là non mais
est-ce que vous gardez la maison c'est
quoi est ce que vous vous êtes imposé
mais c'est un échange
c'est un échange je veux dire je n'ai je
ne vais pas fait un coup d'état je me
suis présenté au conseil fédéral
personne ne s'est présenté face à moi ça
veut dire que ce parti a peut-être aussi
besoin d'unité c'est peut-être pour ça
que je suis là parce qu'on sait que je
ne suis pas un homme de conflit donc
comprendre idées pour rendre un jour la
maison j'ai pas vocation à la garder
mais à la mi janvier je mets ça me va
très bien je sais bien tout le monde a
plein d'ambition il faut s'accrocher à
son poste domicile du flou quittera le
gras mais moi je vous ai bien réagir
bien je vais bien être sain seen as tu
si axa s'il faut repartir un moment et
recultivée et je le ferai je dis
simplement que le moment où cécile
duflot gérer ce mouvement était un
mouvement d'opposition
nous sommes maintenant dans une période
différente nous sommes au gouvernement
nous avons des groupes au parlement
nous sommes dans une autre situation
donc ce que je fais là ne peut en aucune
manière être ce qu'a fait cécile duflot
maintenant me dire je suis dans la
continuité de ce qu'a fait cécile duflot
dans la continuité de ce qu'a porté dany
dans le cas des européennes et de ce que
nicolas hulot a fait dans le pacte
écologique
je le dis oui et je le revendique et
j'espère être un carrefour de ces
différentes cultures est ce que vous
regrettez que daniel cohn bendit ce soit
justement éloigné de rap logique j'ai
déjà dit je pense qu'il reviendra
j'ai aucun problème d'ailleurs il est
revenu sur notre dame des landes en
donnant un excellente interview dans la
presse écrite je fais le pari là aussi
que daniel cohn bendit sera là au moment
des européennes et que il nous permettra
de réussir à nouveau une belle campagne
en 2004 avec nicolas hulot c'est un
nouveau mentor en politique ce qu'il est
c'est à dire mais engager les yonne que
j'admire et j'ai pas honte de le dire
c'est qu'on n'est pas tout le temps
obligé là non plus dans la critique dany
a fait énormément
nicolas lui aussi il ya plein d'autres
personnes que j'aime en politique il
serait bien de type d'écologistes ceux
qui veulent les postes tandis qu'il y à
une course aux postes chez certains on
va pas tous les cycles et revient ici
et puis d'autres qui n'accepte pas les
postes peut-être nicolas hulot et vous
je ne sais pas ministre c'est pas un
fantasme
ah non du tout du tout mais moi j'ai
qu'un seul fantasme c'est de faire en
sorte que l'écologie politique soit
forte et reconnue dans ce pays
voilà ça me sam suffit et tous les
matins et tous les soirs ça me suffit
pour passer la journée en parlais tout à
l'heure de violence en politique
d'affrontement va peut-être dire un mot
de l'ump cet après midi françois fillon
et jean françois copé se sont mis
d'accord pour un référendum sur leur
vote pour prendre la tête de l'ump
vous trouvez cette situation ce soir
comment cocasse tragi en tout cas ça ne
fait pas rire onet manger les légumes
tout à l'heure j'ai trop de respect pour
la politique pour voir ces querelles
bon je n'ai toujours pas bien compris à
ce stade quels en étaient les fondements
moi ce que je sais c'est que la droite a
une vraie question à se poser c'est quel
est son avenir
comment elle veut construire est ce qu
elle veut se construire comme en italie
sur le modèle de berlusconi n'a pas
construit mais oui mais moi c'est ça qui
me préoccupe
après que la droite choisit son chef
c'est un parti bonapartiste depuis
toujours l'ump comme l'était le rpr
cette droite bonapartiste elle a besoin
d'un chef
donc quand elle a plus de chefs elle est
perdue et donc elle sait elle se déchire
et se sépare en attendant est ce que
vous connaissez j'enfonce à côté quand
votre interlocuteur de logis je
reconnais je vais l'ump choisira
absolument qu'il veut pour mettre à la
tête de ce mouvement la seule chose que
j'attends moi c'est quelle ligne
politique
j'ai très peur j'ai très très content
envoyé deux dérives fini en coop et de
ligne politique
j'ai en tout cas j'ai vu j'ai vu comme
j'ai senti une fracture dans le cadre de
la campagne mais en amont de
même de nicolas sarkozy j'ai senti un
moment un basculement vers un discours
qui était un discours qui se rapprocher
de celui de la droite extrême pour pas
dire de l'extrême droite ça ça
m'inquiète je suis un républicain et un
démocrate et j'avais salué le courage de
nathalie kosciusko morizet sam avait été
reproché d'ailleurs en interne c'est pas
grave je l'assument
quand elle avait su fixer une barre en
disant la droite républicaine n'a rien à
faire avec les valeurs du front que sur
les deux candidats qui se respecte jour
il y en a un qui a plus votre préférence
donc se comprend bien où on va dire que
dans l'expression publique et c'est très
important pour un homme politique je
pense que monsieur copé est allé
beaucoup trop loin dans un certain
nombre d'expressions qui l'a utilisé je
pense qu'il faut faire attention aux
mots et surtout quand on a vocation à
diriger un état comme il le répète à
maintes reprise et demain donc vous
rencontrerez le chef de l'état autour du
rapport de le de lionel jospin ce que
son rapport va assez loin pour vous dans
le renouvellement démocratique
la rénovation démocratique vous pensez
bien que je vais pas vous répondre oui
il ya des avancées notamment sur le
statut du chef de l'état sur le fait
qu'ils font très de la proportionnelle
sur la nécessité d'un certain nombre de
réformes y compris territoriales ce sont
des avancées je ne vais évidemment pas
les lainiers les points très faible
selon vous le point faible c'est par
exemple pourcentage de proportionnelle
enfin c'est par exemple mais vous pas au
moins ou qui au moins une centaine de
dépose qu'on réclame c'est le plus
possible mais je vais être je vais être
raisonnablement raisonnablement 20% nous
renouons penser que 20% une chance
inouïe tourner dans 10 ans et ça change
tout parce que ça veut dire par exemple
sur un pour un parti qui à 10%
ça fait 5 et une cinquième ou
franchement cinq députés ne sait pas
grand chose quand on sait qu'un groupe
en plus c'est 15
donc moi je pense qu'il faut aller plus
loin là dessus je j'aimerais donc sur la
proportionnelle c'est très important
j'aimerais aussi qu'on aille un peu plus
loin sur les réformes territoriales que
l'on fasse en sorte que les scrutins
bouge et que les régions prennent un
autre un autre une autre ampleur
j'aimerais aussi que les communautés
urbaines puisse est maintenant reconnue
et qu'on puisse aller
suffrage direct sur les élections des
communautés parce que il faut dépasser
là aussi le schéma que que nous
connaissons depuis les années la france
bouge il faut qu' il faut que nos
conditions électorales bouger avec et
sur la limitation du cumul des mandats
ya beaucoup de réticences ici au sénat
et ce qu'il faudrait un statut
spécifique pour les sénateurs moi je
veux bien qu'on pose la question du
sénat mais alors on la pose complètement
on pose complètement la chambre des
régions principe d'une chambre des
régions par examen et oui mais moi ça me
va très bien
c'est fait quelque chose ça fait très
longtemps on est nous des européens
convaincus
l'europe des régions c'est une
signification pour nous et il faut que
la république française trouve les bons
éléments
donc moi une réforme du sénat avec
pourquoi pas en rayon sport donc mais on
remet à plat on remet à plat comme comme
pour l'énergie comme pour notre dame des
landes il faut dialoguer et si vous me
dites le cumul des mandats au sénat doit
être peut-être vu différemment parce que
il faut des élus locaux
pourquoi pas je dis bien pourquoi pas
mais pas dans le cadre actuel du sénat
là c'est pas ça du tout qu'on veut une
dernière question avec notre partenaire
orange et leur application tv tchèque
sur la politique étrangère et notamment
proche orient est ce que vous voyez une
vraie différence depuis l'élection de
françois hollande d'un côté il ya eu
l'annoncé cet après-midi par laurent
fabius qui a précisé donc que la france
allait défendre le droit de la palestine
à devenir un pays à part entière au sein
de l'onu donc ça c'est à qui d'autre est
là donc c'est donc une première une
première avancée mais bien sûr que je
vois une différence sur ce que ce que
fait pascal canfin
sous la houlette de laurent fabius et
évidemment du président de la république
dans le cadre des rapports avec
l'afrique et avec un certain nombre pays
d'amérique latine
évidemment c'est une transformation
totale c'est une dernière question à
vous poser est ce que vous trouvez
légitime l'intervention de nicolas
sarkozy pour régler la crise à l'ump je
n'ai pas d'avis là dessus je n'ai pas
calé lequel est la manière dont nicolas
sarkozy se situe par rapport à il joue
un rôle en coulisses et revendiquée
les rôles en coulisse m'ennuie toujours
moi je suis pour la transparence d'une
manière générale je l'avais dit pour
anne lauvergeon je la préfère autour
d'une table qu'en coulisses c'est
exactement la même chose si nicolas
sarkozy a envie de jouer un rôle
politique mais bien sûr en face et il a
été président de la république pendant
cinq ans il a toute légitimité pour
continuer à faire de la politique même
qu'aux membres du conseil
constitutionnel de droit ça c'est un
autre débat la question mais ce rapt est
retranché dans la réforme justement la
dame et ça c'est fait s'est pour sa part
dit sûr c'est que en l'état en l'état de
la loi il a la possibilité d'y aller
voilà maintenant je pense qu'on pourrait
revoir l'informatique 'le conseil
constitutionnel merci beaucoup parce
qu'elle dehors d'avoir été avec no mercy
pérenne en zappant ou la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera michel sapin
ministre du travail bonsoir à tous
c'est vrai que je ne m'explique pas je
reste moi-même c'est ma force
ce que vous voyez ici c'est ce que je
suis je n'aime pas les honneurs des
protocoles les palais je revendique une
simplicité qui n'est pas une retenue
mais la marque de l'authentic autorités
ça c'était françois hollande nu par
lui-même
mais qui est vraiment cet homme qui a
conquis le pouvoir sur le thème de la
normalité est il si simple que ça se
montre t-il vraiment en permanence tel
qu'il est et que nous dit sur lui ses
premiers mois à l'elysée
cette semaine des as billon en tout bien
tout honneur le mois et le surmoi du
locataire de l'elysée
déshabillons-les présentée par hélène
risser demain à 18h15 sur public sénat
c'est des gens qui habitent en
appartement qui ont que les belges
seront énoncées lors c'est leur part de
rêve d'évasion
les soucis et le stress du quotidien
sont laissés à l'entrée le temps d'une
matinée
chaque samedi il se retrouve au jardin
un petit coin de campagne en plein coeur
de la ville de poitiers ont fait ça dans
la joie et la bonne humeur
quelques habitants ont fait de ce
terrain inconstructible un potager
associatif ouvert à tous
bénédicte vous occuper d'une association
qui gère un jardin collectif c'est quoi
un jardin collectif alors c'est un
jardin qui a ici un demi-hectare prêté
par la mairie à minsk était louée par la
municipalité de poitiers dans lequel on
fait des cultures collective on a un
marché qu'on embauche et chaque semaine
chaque adhérent peut avoir son panier de
légumes
quasiment sur toute l'année avec
l'adversaire pour cela ils s'engagent à
participer
un samedi matin par mois la récolte aux
divers travaux et chaque samedi là son
panier avant on connaissait les jardins
ouvriers
il laisse place désormais aux jardins
collectifs le besoin de se reconnecter à
la nature de retrouver le goût du vrai
c'est la contrepartie d'être toujours
chez pas devant la télé l'ordinateur le
téléphone portable et cetera dans un
monde très artificielle et puis
finalement on s'aperçoit que obligé de
revenir un peu à la nature que la
qualité de la nourriture et pas
forcément garantie alors tout au moins
peut-être que son aspect est garanti
quand on va au supermarché mais la
qualité nutritive est ce qu'on est sûr
qu'il ya pas de produits de traitement
non tout ça on n'est pas sûr donc sans
doute que ça inquiète les gens c'est
pour ça qu'on a adhéré à l'association
c'est d'être sûr de la façon dont les
légumes sont produits on participe on
est sûr qu'ils apportent produits de
traitement mettre la main à la terre un
souvenir d'enfance pour certains une
découverte pour les autres retraités
employés étudiants les générations se
mélangent échange un moment convivial où
tous viennent chercher plus que des
légumes et qui a dit que les plus jeunes
n'écoutez pas les conseils de leurs
aînés
c'est sympa sur l'apprentissage aussi
parce que du coup ne connaît pas les
mêmes choses qu'eux mêmes choses que
nous et dans la discussion assez sympa
de voir la vision des choses différentes
des gens qui peuvent nous apprendre des
choses aussi parce que ces interviews ce
sera avec des fleurs qu'est ce que c'est
il ya des gens qui sont là pour dire ah
mais oui alors ça c'est d'aimer perds tu
peux faire ça ça ça avec ses manières
d'apprendre plus un paquet à six dont
une classe à chaque panier reçoit la
même quantité de légumes 70 à garnir au
total le partage bien sûr et par les
temps qui courent
l' envie de manger bio un moindre coût
on s'engage pour une année en fait une
saison 355 euros pour le tarif ordinaire
pour faire un tarif aussi réduit
c'est jeu des deux à trois dernières
années on estimait que les légumes
récoltés sur l'année coûtait en commerce
entre 500 et 600 euros en fait il ya une
réelle économie c'est quasiment manche
deux fois moins cher pour ainsi dire
chez les urbains les jardins ont la cote
et la crise y est sûrement pour quelque
chose
même au jardin des plantes du centre
ville on trouve un potager pédagogique
celui ci ce sont les jardiniers
municipaux qui sont occupe mais les
habitants peuvent s'y servir sans excès
pour goûter les légumes ou plantes
médicinales qu'ils ne connaissent pas
l'idée c'est quoi c'est qu' on puisse
enfin que la collectivité donne la
possibilité aux habitants de
s'approprier l'espace le public est de
rendre réellement à la terre ça
fonctionne nourricière c'est à dire
qu'au lieu de mettre des fleurs ou une
pelouse qui sert simplement à à créer un
visuel agréable et bien les habitants
puissent
jardiner faire pousser ou les carottes
des poireaux des tomates a fait des
choses de simple des salades
alors c'est révolutionnaire pour
beaucoup transformé le monde res passe
laissé à l'abandon en jardins collectifs
les poitevins en rêve les demandes
augmentent
d'autres projets sont en cours dans
plusieurs quartiers de la ville et
l'adjointe au maire espère bien les voir
sortir de terre une parcelle collective
et elle elle oblige si on peut dire à
travailler à jardiner avoir des loisirs
avec d'autres elle oblige aussi à
partager la récolte et là je trouve que
ça rompt avec l'individualisme qui nous
habite tous ces pistes de cette société
comme ça
près de mille jardins partagés
existerait déjà en france réintroduire
la nature en ville
l'idée fait son chemin nous sommes
toujours à poitiers mais ici jardiner
permet de remettre sur pied ceux qui ont
décroché